we have to move so quick that a
four-year degree is too slow to school
and our educational system needs to be
adjusted very very quickly if you think
by having that certificate by having a
diploma by having that degree you are
guarantee success you off delusional
schools failing entrepreneurs every
single day because it's not built for
entrepreneurship it's built for workers
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today we're gonna
talk about why the traditional education
system needs to be reformed and I'd love
to hear your thoughts as well also if
you want to know a grant cardone garyvee
Elon Musk and others have to say about
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence the link
to join is in the description below
there are times when something is
important enough you believe in it
enough that you do you do it in spite of
fear
you have to go build self-confidence the
reason people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much
ok let's kick it up with Patrick Beit
David who says we need to learn
continuously if I was to ask you this
one question here watch this how many
guys have a four-year degree raised and
if you got a four-year degree okay now
watch this keep your hands up please
keep your hand up I'm really curious how
many of you that have a four-year degree
in the last 30 days you've finished a
business book that's the problem
why so what's the point of a degree some
some ants are still up was it just to
get a degree in that education is gonna
be done you know what that's kind of
like me saying that's like me saying to
following when I was 14 to 18 years old
I exercise every day and that's it come
on man how we stay in shape you know I
don't know why my six-pack is not coming
I used to have it when I was 22 I'm 42
no no we need to workout today
right we need to educate ourselves today
now what we did 20 years ago so I don't
have any problem with our people that
get degrees I have a problem with us not
endorsing self education I have a
problem with the fact that we need four
years to go to college nowadays where
snapchat comes out the next thing comes
out the next thing comes out we have to
move so quick that a four year degrees
too slow to school at our educational
system needs to be adjusted very very
quickly
next is Elon Musk who says schools need
to be more engaging they're definitely
some good schools out there but I think
the some of the space of the mistakes at
least in my opinion that I see being
made in education is that people the
teachers do not explain why kids are
being taught a subject you know just
sort of get dumped into math and like
why are you letting with what's the
point of this those seems like some you
know some people like maybe it's I don't
know why I'm being asked to do these
strange problems but you know the why of
things is extremely important because
you know our brain has evolved to not to
discard information that it thinks is
has a relevance so then if on the one
hand you you'll be asked to memorize or
learn say formulas but you don't not
know why this is the case then you have
this cognitive dissonance of it seems
irrelevant but I'm being told to
remember it so I'll be punished so so I
better remember it but so the why of
things is very important and then being
able to attend it and then picking kind
of a problem and then using various
educational tools to solve that problem
like using math or physics or economics
to to solve that problem is far more
engaging than teaching the tools you
know sniffers between if you say well
we're gonna take apart this this engine
and and see how it works and put it back
together again
and then in order to take the engine
apart we need you know wrenches and
screwdrivers and a way
inch and allen keys and whatnot
and and I said that and then in the
course of solving the problem of taking
the engine apart and putting it back
together
you learn about branches and
screwdrivers and all the tools that you
need and then now you understand the
relevance this is why the wrenches are
important I what you know where's if you
had a class on wrenches why this not
seem that great you know so tying it to
solving a problem is I think very
powerful for establishing relevance and
getting kids excited about what they're
working on and then and and having the
knowledge stick next is Dan Locke who
says College creates employees College
itself it's not designed to teach you
how to be financially successful it is
not designed to teach you how to be
successful in life even because college
and university they are designed for one
thing and one thing only do you know
what that is that's the crate employees
because you study the history of
Education how it was created this
multi-billion dollar industry Multi
multi billion on industry is to create
workers because if look back back then
with all the the Industrial Age all the
companies are the titans what they found
out is ok we are growing we don't have
enough workers we don't have enough
employees we need to create a system
that could produce and create an
infinite amount of workers that will
work within our companies that's how
basically school system is to be created
our society if you think about it you
study it that's what happens so if you
understand that it's designed for that
it is designed to keep you locked up in
a job it's designed to keep you in one
place where you go to school then guess
what what did what did it teach you yes
can't just student loan debt and then
after you graduate you get a job and
then what do you do you then you climb
that corporate ladder
and after whatever 10 20 years if you
are good you might move into you like a
middle management position that's if you
don't get downsized if the company
doesn't go out of business and then with
a little bit luck then maybe when you're
65 you'll retire with little bit of
money leaving a pension that's how the
entire system is designed to do it's
designed to keep you following this path
what I'm saying is this instead of
asking is college worth it yes you meet
some people you did learn some basic
skills you're going to communicate you
learn something basic about everything
little bit about everything that's okay
I think what I the way I see it is
college is not enough I think that's
what I'm saying that if you think by
having that certificate by having a
diploma by having a degree you are
guarantee success you are delusional
you're in you're in la-la land it is not
enough if you think after you graduate
that's all the learning that you need to
do hey I work hard I work hard for four
or five years in school I'm taking my
exams I'm doing my homework if you think
that's enough for you to be successful
in life that's not just not true you
need way more way more education I'm not
talking about formal education formal
education makes you a living self
education makes you a fortune next is
Gary P who says schools are failing
entrepreneurs who always successful in
everything but school didn't do well
school poor terrible actually punted it
you know it was funny and this is where
I give my parents enormous credit and
I've you know it's funny it's a business
book that says self-awareness my parents
grew up and I give them so much credit
in a world where all their
contemporaries as and you know this
education is the way out for immigrants
my mom recognized that I was a merchant
an entrepreneur a promoter at school
fail you or you failed school school
failed me schools failing entrepreneurs
every single day it was because it's not
built for entrepreneurship it's built
for workers you know if you're being
taught to play within the lines
there's nothing being taught that maps
to the entrepreneurial market as a
matter of fact my biggest cynicism when
I sit across an entrepreneur today is if
they are too successful at school I
probably look at Ivy League grad
starting startups right now with more of
a negative light than I do somebody who
wasn't as good because what I've learned
over the last five to seven years and by
the way in the last two or three years
I've taken a step back on this because
there's too many entrepreneurial friends
who've gone to great schools that have
been successful so this is not a blanket
statement but I will tell you that in a
world of private schools in a world of
mommy and daddy having a lot of
connections that when you go from 12 15
18 years of that ecosystem and you go
into a market and you create an app the
market doesn't give a crap who your dad
is the market responds to your product
and a lot of these kids have not been
able to take the punch in the mouth that
comes along with entrepreneurship next
is Mark Cuban and Seth Godin who say
that the debt is not worth it my advice
to a junior or about to be senior in
high school is go to the cheapest school
possible to get your freshman and maybe
sophomore classes you don't need to go
to Harvard Harvard you know introduction
to writing and freshman English and
freshness sociology okay you can make an
argument it's gonna be better than you
know Joe Blow junior college or
Community College but the reality is you
have to weigh that against if you're
paying for your school or more
importantly if you're borrowing money
for your school do you want to be
saddled with 40 50 80 $100,000 in debt
I'll give up you know the incremental
value of freshman English at a great
school to not have the the stress you
know just physically on you and your
family and I think all that's going to
change like I went to Indiana I love
Indiana I always recommend going to
Indiana are you boo-hoo-hoo-hoo Jers but
the price for out-of-state has gotten
ridiculous and they want me to build
this building they have Tony if your
school is building business building
buildings your school is
but but every school is building
buildings exactly that's my point of my
post it's like the newspaper industry
right more printing presses more big
buildings right makes this look grander
we have brains than we're putting them
out there there's there's a point of
diminishing returns in terms of what
it's worth for a college education and
how much debt you're willing to sell
yourself with I mean $40,000 in debt
that's a shitload of money
I don't want $40,000 in debt you know
it's just I think decision points have
got to be different schools have got
more administrators making over $200,000
a year than they have profs you know and
then the people that they're saying are
the greatest educators that you getting
you're getting all your money's worth
here they're paying fifteen hundred two
thousand five thousand dollars a class
and those people have to have other jobs
and so there's just you and I both do
the same thing we look for industries
that are ripe for disruption because
they do things the way they've always
done them and I think universities
four-year universities are doing it and
and it's a real problem and so I told IU
that I will not do anything that
involves buildings and I've told other
or you know universities and
organizations the same thing you know
I'd rather see you implode all those I
mean the sociology building the business
building the psychology building what's
different in any of the classrooms okay
you got a desk you got something the
wall you got you know audio-visual
materials computer Wi-Fi video
conferencing whatever you don't need a
special building so you know the psych
professors can cuz they have beards and
they need two different groomy things in
the bathrooms it just makes no sense and
so I think it's and you combine that
with easy money it's easy to borrow
money for school then you have inflation
you have school prices that are run
ramped up and it's going to implode just
like real estate did from easy money
here's what I think is going to happen
there is clearly a higher education
bubble it is clearly going to burst but
it is going to burst slowly and the way
it's gonna be burst slow it's gonna be
nibbled to death by people like you and
me that around the edges if we can just
train
people to become curious and thirsty the
number of other things they can learn is
so big they don't have to pay a quarter
of a million dollars for certification
because the like every course that MIT
teaches is for you're about to be free
so what's the quarter million dollars
votes for the piece of paper the proof
so what's going to happen bit by bit the
way the internet usually does things is
you're going to be able to create a body
of work that lets the employer know
you're worth hiring now it's not as
convenient as the mit certificate but
it's actually gonna be more powerful
yeah it's gonna take a while but that's
I think the future and so we're gonna
see more and more free stuff I'm gonna
see more and more expensive stuff we're
going to see networks built guilds like
in the Middle Ages the guild was
everything so if I had more energy I
build a guild and say here are five
thousand people we spend three hours a
day training we're all networked with
each other higher one of us you hire all
of us and we put our reputation on each
one of these five thousand people what
would that be worth
that would be worth easy three thousand
dollars a month for every one of those
people right that's a huge industry by
itself but if you actually pick the
right five thousand people that would be
worth more than any diploma and the last
point before a very special bonus clip
is with Grant Cardone who says it's only
useful for specific traits
basically the traditional school system
is because parents are lazy we're lazy
it's a place to send them so that we
don't have to be with them I mean if
everybody just got honest it's it's it's
okay don't you go to school it's good
for the government they like all the
money it produces tremendous amount of
money that gets to go to that so they
can do whatever they do with that money
everybody agrees worldwide the school
systems are terrible except maybe in
certain parts of Asia in America it's
awful even the private school the best
schools I mean all the way up to college
all the way up to the big schools so
people are you know in college people
are studying five hours a week that's
not that
no study time 60% of the kids are not
getting out of college in four years 40%
are still not out after six years
it's an awful waste of money in time we
think hey so we want a home school we
hey what do we want them schooled in you
know what the experiences of life are
more valuable than just something that
comes out of a book we believe and
people I think I think more and more
people are waking up to the idea of
challenging the traditional school
system we had an interview we had a
resume sent to us the other day and the
guy started spouting off all the schools
he went to and I'm like he'll never make
it here it's crazy I held it against him
because he was highly educated that I
have many young followers and they're
asking me this question should I finish
my school or should I start a business
uh-huh I have this dream to start a
business
should I wait that I finish the school
and then I chased my dream or do I chase
my dream and just forget about the
school so I think I think that I would
tell them look you shouldn't do either
you know you should go get a job yeah
you should get a job working for someone
that's in in the space that you want to
be in it's already going down the road
right that has experience that has
gunpowder money that had that has
courage and is written taking risk
already I I think that a lot of people
that start in business they shouldn't
that should know I look I got guys
working for me
Jarrod's you're gonna make a couple
million dollars this year he's a
millionaire already he's been with me
seven or eight years Ryan the pilot he's
gonna he's working in the real estate
space these guys could never get on
their own as fast is working with
somebody like me yeah so people have
this idea that you have to be your your
own your own your own boss sister is
ridiculous I'm not even my own boss I
don't work for myself then I work for a
lot of other people so there's no such
thing as about the boss you know I work
for other people I have to be on time at
other things there's you're always going
to be answering to someone the Queen
she's she answers to people too yeah
everybody answers to someone
so there's no such thing as I'm gonna be
my own guy if that's why you want to get
in a business for yourself definitely
the wrong thing to do but staying in
college like if you could do college in
two years then do it and get out and
work on the weekends but if it's gonna
take you four or five or six years of
income unless you're a doctor unless
you're a very very specific trade a
professor maybe yeah well but what's he
gonna do - for the world he's gonna work
at the place that some dropout funded
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Warren Buffett and his thoughts but
before that I want to know what are your
thoughts what are your thoughts on the
traditional education system what are
your thoughts on its usefulness who do
you think it is good for and what
suggestions for reform do you have that
hopefully can spark a conversation and
maybe make some change I'd love to hear
from you in the comments below
in my experience in business there is
very little difference if any between a
very high-priced business education and
what's available a lot for a lot less
money so I I mean I I went to the
University of nebraska-lincoln my last
year in college I went to Wharton for a
couple years before that I learned just
as much at the university of brass
because I did a warden at and there's
nothing against war denomination we had
a very good school there I had some
terrific professors at Lincoln and so I
would not assume that if I was paying a
few thousand dollars for an education
here in the state for example versus
paying huge amounts elsewhere that it
was going to make a lot of difference
most of a lot of the education you need
to be prodded in the right direction but
an awful lot of it is so the cells talk
I mean Andrew Carnegie did a wonderful
thing in this country in terms of
libraries and I used to spend a lot of
time allows I can get locked in at the
University of all my ones what was then
the University of Omaha and they had
their I couldn't get out for hours and I
got so entranced with what I was reading
but it there's there's all kinds of
information available not with the
internet it's so much you know easier
than I was then so period it's out there
to be taken and it isn't necessary to
pay thirty or thirty-five thousand
dollars a year to go to some big-name
school to get the education at all I
mean if you're gonna learn accounting if
you're going which is probably the most
important of course you take in business
you're gonna learn accounting learn
accounting absolutely as well and my
view going to you and always going to
Harvard I mean I see I would bet on
and so I wouldn't rob huge bills in
terms of getting a business education
now you know if you're gonna get a
medical education I mean there's certain
professions where there may not be any
way around spending a fair amount of
money and getting in debt to some degree
even got to make that decision yourself
but I certainly try to minimize it and
and I would sort of I would have it
figured out how I wouldn't handle that
debt and say a five-year period after I
got out of school or I would think twice
about incurring it raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
that people passion and not one drop of
most self-worth depends on your
acceptance of a
if you want some advice some mal Robbins
and Gary Vee on should you quit the job
that you hate check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
I would not be an incredibly successful
entrepreneur and neither would he if we
hadn't failed or showed up at a bunch of
jobs first